[Music]
train to busan so train to busan is a
south korean horror film it's a zombie
apocalypse film that takes place on a
train
it was trending when it came to netflix
last summer and a lot of people you
people i know in real life you were all
like dude
you gotta watch this movie because it's
awesome and i was like wait
october's coming up i'm gonna save that
review
for october because you know sounds like
a halloween movie you need halloween
movies and
obviously my grab bag for horror movies
isn't decades old and now this review's
not going to get one-third to views it
would have gotten had i reviewed it last
summer when it was trending when it came
to netflix point is train to busan is
yet another
two-hour example of south korean movies
being amazing proof that them being
amazing isn't a new thing but it's new
to some of us
in america who haven't had a lot of
exposure to them so the plot of the
movie is a simple one there's this guy
he's a bit of an absentee father he's a
businessman you kind of get the feeling
he's
a bit of a scumbag for the job he has a
few people without referencing boiler
room are pretty much like you're like
one of the dudes from boiler room or
wall street you know you get it this
guy's daughter's like hey i want to
visit my mom
in busan so they take yes a train
to busan all the while you see the
beginnings of what looks like a zombie
apocalypse sprouting up in the
background because this is not our first
zombie apocalypse ride then zombie
outbreak on the moving train
and [ __ ] gets real but as it's a zombie
apocalypse movie okay how were the
thrills the chills the zombie scares
yeah they're in here it's actually
not the most violent zombie movie i've
seen
but i've noticed as i've gotten older i
don't always require
violence some movies could benefit for
having more violence like i said in my
scream 3 review
that movie could have but for a zombie
apocalypse movie like this i just i need
the anxiety i need the intensity when
people die i i would like a bit of blood
this movie does have that but it's not
nearly as violent to say the walking
dead but it's also 10 times more
effective
and intense than the walking dead so
there's that and going into this movie i
was just i was
interested as to how they were going to
keep a two-hour movie going that just
takes place on a train
but they absolutely do 100 of it doesn't
take place on a train there is a
momentary
stop that they make but the intensity is
always there
first of all when they're on the train
the zombies start sprouting they're not
just you know they're not walking dead
slow ass zombies they're the zack
snyder's dawn of the dead you know they
get bit they die they're quick to snap
right back up and join the horde army of
the zombie apocalypse that
claustrophobic feeling with fast
zombies intense right out the gate but
what i loved about this movie is that
even when there's
a moment where you feel like they could
probably stop and breathe you know they
shouldn't so
none of you stop to breathe they don't
stop to breathe you don't stop to
breathe there's no time that fight or
flight feeling of perpetual anxiety
is always there as michael knight from
knight rider would say
keep your scanners peeled you know you
always have to you have to have your
head on a swivel you're always on high
alert and this movie reminds you why you
always should be and i love that in this
movie if we're going to reference
zack snyder's dawn of the dead again
which is one of those movies it's one of
those remake movies where
it should have sucked but didn't i think
it's a great zombie apocalypse movie but
there is a point in that movie where it
looks like everyone just kind of gets
comfortable you know they're sitting
around the dinner table they're talking
about the jobs that they were best and
worst at you can call it the calm before
the storm but i just appreciated the
fact that in train to busan
there's no calm there's just storm and
part of what keeps that intensity alive
is how
attached i got to the characters this
movie has great character development
character growth
i mean it's a train full of people that
start getting whittled down and becoming
a zombie horde the point is among all
the people on the train of course the
movie's gonna be like hey here are your
five or six
people that we're actually going to give
character development too those are the
ones you get attached to and among those
protagonists
i didn't want any of them to die yes i'm
saying that's kind of weird right like
at least it is for me in a zombie
scenario like this usually be like all
right of you six
you three i want you to live you three
looking forward to seeing how you die
not that you're bad people not that i
want you to die but i'm just saying i'm
looking forward to some death here it's
a zombie movie when it comes to cinema
you can be down to enjoy all the good
and the evil that a movie has to offer
you can root for the people to live
and also root for the zombies to eat a
few you know for entertainment just like
you can root for arthur fleck to
overcome his problems hopefully but
also look forward to the fact that he's
probably gonna shoot murray in the face
you can look forward to all of it it's
good and evil it's cinema but no
in train to busan i really got attached
to everybody because they start getting
attached to each other
there's real growth there some
characters didn't like each other at
first but they grow on each other it's
it's like an rpg they're your crew you
want them all to live
and that definitely adds to the
intensity anytime
anybody's in mortal peril you feel it
you're like get out of there nobody's
expendable
granted there's there's a character in
here it's like i would love to see you
die horribly but he's not
part of the crew but that character is a
great reflection
of the possible future for our main
character which
again i i love the nuance of that and
this movie is nuanced it's a very
layered film it has a surprising amount
of emotion surprising amount of heart
and has a surprising amount to say about
classism that divide among the classes
is what makes this movie so compelling
it's so naturally woven into the
character development character
progression and plot which fundamentally
just
makes it feel better than how hollywood
does it hollywood has a message to give
it has all the nuance of a semi landing
on your head all of this is to say train
to busan
was epic it's that good great characters
that you get attached to
great thrills great emotional tone the
attachment you get with the characters
that grabs you the intensity you feel
with the zombies
that takes you on the roller coaster i
haven't enjoyed a zombie story this much
in many years i walked away from train
to busan thinking
one word awesome tacular
[Music]
hyped up movies don't always live up to
the hype but this one
definitely deserved all the praise
you're looking for a sweet zombie movie
it's on amazon prime right now
go check it out all right so train to
busan have you seen it what did you
think about it or what's another piece
of korean cinema
that is another two hour piece of proof
that korean cinema truly does kick ass
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you